Oh back in August I got arrested for a
stun I did protesting SeaWorld and I was
sentenced to 30 days in jail whoa
here's how that went here we are
December 9th 2015 today I'm going to
jail
I'm entire how I'm doing it this is
County Line go on her surf set slept
less than three hours last night so I'm
going to get as tired as possible sleep
yeah first let's catch some waves I'm
gonna have to take this thing out that
or I can just not tell them about it
why do you think it out my name I could
maybe pick pick the lock or something
not exactly the session the Sanj better
help me sleep a little bit time to go
meet bring a food cupboard slammer all
showered up this is what I'm going to
wear veggie girl they look at your game
your closet game is sick dude ah quinoa
power salad by Gupta black beans
dupa de Mountain food it's beer been to
jail before I went to jail so many times
my butthole fell off was it worth it
dude oh hell yeah
buck zero yeah I officially cannot eat
one more [ __ ] thing oh my god I'm
ready to sleep 4:05 oh that's my collect
call number you'll be receiving a call
Correctional Facility
and made reception
here we are at my hotel and this is my
reservation yeah I don't know about
water didn't count those little
misty-eyed you want me to work must be
new as well as really bro
Oh all right nothing asking my medical
problems other than being like a little
bit of an alcoholic and drug addict like
I'm pretty good rather clean and sober
for quite a while I don't know if I want
to work no it's silly but it's time for
me to spread my videos we go
okay
eight hours I know
yeah well thanks how was that down dere
like I didn't even get a chance to sleep
they gave me a hood cuz I was all
excited to read impressed I got not
first I'm going to sleep I'm gonna sleep
then and then like I was barely asleep
for like maybe an hour - okay we're cut
you lose like there ha ha ha badly oh no
snooze button oh yeah they're so big
thanks to everybody at the Twin Tower
Correctional Facility my mug shot that
was [ __ ] hilarious I can't believe
they let me do that ah and what else man
it's been a long time since I put up one
of these videos I'm excited about it and
I think I'm gonna have to get back into
the groove so expect to see more respect
the like button I will see you soon
we subscribe